Guten Morgen Linus.
Guten Morgen Tim.
Mir fällt kein Witz ein.
Mehr auch nicht.
Nicht immer alles so lustig was da draußen passiert. Manchmal geht's einem ganz schön auf den Senkel. Nachrichtenlage ist auch dürftig man kann sich noch nicht mal richtig über irgendjemand lustig machen. Das finde ich gemein und äh eine Missachtung des Podcastgeschäfts.
Oder?
Ja, da müssen wir auf jeden. Das äh führt zu einer sofortigen Konjunkturflaute. Da sollte jetzt auf jeden Fall äh die Politik was unternehmen.
Ja, da müssen Maßnahmen ergriffen werden und zwar kurzfristig, um die Gemüter zu beruhigen.
Kurzfristig und langfristig brauchen wir einen Konjunkturpaket für mehr äh politische Schönheit.
Stimmt, das wäre ganz gut. Ja.
Aber gibt's nicht. Stattdessen äh gibt's trotz alledem hier äh unserer einhundertzweiundzwanzigste Ausgabe,
Zeit gefunden haben, uns mal wieder über die Ferne,
zusammenzufinden, wenn auch nicht ganz so fern wie noch vor kurzem auch ausreichend, dass wir auf wackelige Internetprotokolle angewiesen sind, um uns miteinander zu unterhalten.
Und gehackte WLANs.
Und.
Ja, meinst du, ich zahle hier irgendwie zwanzig Euro am Tag.
Ich hab die Wahl zwischen vier und zehn Mbit. Kann ich mir aussuchen.
Wow, toll.
Ist sehr gut. So.
Aber alle sind dagegen und alle, alle, alle, alle wollen immer alles verhindern. Auch äh verhindern wollen die Republikaner in den USA,
den äh Freedom-Act, der zumindest vorhatte, äh den Patriot-Act ein wenig äh irgendwelche Züge anzuziehen, aber das geht natürlich schon mal gar nicht wegen Terror.
Ja
Genau, es ging darum, man, das war so diese der erste, die ersten Reformbemühungen in den in den USA, die trugen so die Handschrift, äh dessen, dass den US-Bürgern ja im Prinzip ähm,
alles egal ist
wenn sie selber betroffen sind, das ist ja auch finde ich völlig legitim, wenn das jeder so macht, dann äh ist auch an alle gedacht. Und deswegen sagten die Amerikaner, wir möchten ungerne,
Ähm dass äh wir, dass unsere Metadaten hier gesammelt werden,
und die US-Regierung darauf einen äh direkten Zugriff hat. Äh deswegen wollten sie dann ähm also komme ich gleich zu, was sie da gemacht haben. Also sie wollten diese diese äh.
Massen und vollständige Überwachung der äh der Meterdaten einschränken,
Sie wollten alle geheimen Gesetze, die der fieser Court, äh also das äh Foren Intelligence Ins Valence,
der Fisk, der Foren Intelligence and Valence Court, der mit dem Foren Intelligence Ins Valence act ins Leben gerufen wurde, äh zurückziehen und sie wollten.
Also einen besonderen Vertreter der der Öffentlichkeit zum zu,
oder des öffentlichen Interesses und der Privatsphäre benennen, der sich in solchen Vorhaben dann äh informiert ähm,
äußern darf. Äh das ging dann ähm erstmal durch Sammet und Haus. Äh dieser dieses äh dieser Entwurf wurde da verwässert,
und äh schließlich war er dann so auf dem Niveau, dass äh selbst seine ursprünglichen Autoren ihn kritisiert haben. Äh die IFF sagte, naja, so wir, das ist jetzt ein Boden,
aber noch keine Decke, was ich sehr, sehr schöner,
ähm ganz sehr schöne Metapher fand, also wir können da jetzt erstmal drauf aufbauen, ja? Aber das ist jetzt noch nicht da, wo wir hinwollen, ne. Haben wir jetzt noch kein Haus. Ähm,
von der ACLU, der äh der American Livertys Union, äh wurde dann so gesagt,
Das wird jetzt nicht jedes Problem mit der äh Überwachung durch unsere Regierung äh lösen, aber es ist ein erster wichtiger ähm,
Schritt und umso mehr ähm verdient er den breiten, die breite Unterstützung.
Ähm das was am Ende überblieb war, dass sie statt dieser Vollüberwachung aller äh Telefonmeterdaten äh und Kontakte eine,
auf achtzehn Monate begrenzte äh dezentrale Vorratsdatenspeicherung haben wollen nach dem äh europäischen Beispiel,
ähm,
wo die Call Metadaten nicht bei der Regierung, sondern bei den Providern gesammelt werden und dann auf Anfrage äh herausgegeben werden.
Das heißt, das, was bei uns äh äh vor kurzem äh als als EU-Richtlinie gekippt wurde, äh darauf auf dieses Niveau wollten die runter mal drei,
nämlich mit achtzehn Monate Speicherdauer. Ähm,
und das contact chaing, also quasi zu sehen, wie viele Hops man dann noch von dem Terroristen weg ist und wen man dann noch alles mit überwachen darf. Das sollte auch weiterhin möglich sein, aber äh ein getrennten Antrag erfordern,
ja. Und äh nun wurde sich entschieden, äh dass eine weitere Debatte über diesen Gesetzesvorschlag.
Für die Zeitdauer für die Legislaturperiode des äh hundertdreizehnten US Cong Congress,
nicht mehr stattfinden würde, weil man nicht die erforderlichen sechzig Stimmen dafür zusammenbekommen hat, dass die Debatte überhaupt weitergeführt wurde. Also das heißt, es wurde die Debatte beendet,
und es wurde noch es war jetzt nicht so als wäre über das Ergebnis abgestimmt worden, ja? Es wurde einfach gesagt, da reden wir noch nicht mal mehr drüber,
Das war dann das traurige Ende.
Des Freedom-Acts, der als Paradebeispiel immer hergehalten hat, äh dass äh die Snowden äh Enthüllungen eine unmittelbare äh Wirkung in die Politik entfaltet hätten.
Tja, wie man mal sieht, der Backlash ist ja enorm, ne? Also es ändert sich einfach mal gar nichts.
Also in den.
Den USA jetzt nach meinem Überblick. Nichts, nee.
Nö, aber hier ja eigentlich auch nicht. Oder, also, ich meine, hat sich eigentlich schon irgendwas geändert? Nicht so richtig.
Weiß ich nicht, kommt drauf an, in welchem Fachbereich man dann unterwegs ist.
Ob ich mal so rein gesetzttechnisch kann ich mich jetzt noch an nichts erinnern, da der Verfassungsschutz kriegt mehr Geld, glaube ich. Das war irgendwie.
Aufwaschungsschutz kriegt mehr Geld. Wir geben jetzt viereinhalb Millionen Euro für Exploits aus. Wir haben IT-Sicherheitsgesetz, da wird eine ganze Menge Papier geschrieben werden. Da haben wir Mindeststandards jetzt demnächst.
Und und mehr Cyber.
Cyber haben wir auch. Nee, also sorry, so, der bleibt aus. Ähm.
So, leider nicht.
Wir hatten, wir hatten noch in Deutschland äh diese Woche einen äh eine eine wie nennt man das, eine Debatte zur WLAN-Störerhaftung. Das wäre doch mal was, das wäre doch mal was. Das soll ein altes Thema, da könnte man jetzt.
Ja da könnte man nochmal was besser machen.
Da könnte man mal was besser machen. Das.
Ja, die die Opposition ist auch dafür.
Dann kann ja nichts mehr passieren, wenn sogar die Opposition dafür ist,
Also es war ein ein Gesetzesvorschlag eingebracht von der Grünen Partei und der linken Partei und zwar geht es da um die Haftungsfreistellung in Paragraph acht des Telemediengesetzes,
für gängige,
äh für gängige Internetprovider, ja? Also das haben wir auch schon öfter hier besprochen. Es geht darum, ähm dass der das eigentlich der Paragraph acht des Telemediengesetzes sagt, wer anderen Zugang zum Internet ermöglicht,
ähm der haftet nicht für deren Handlung, ja? Ähm.
Und das heißt also, die Telekom ist nicht dafür verantwortlich, was äh was ich mache,
Und auch dieses äh was weiß ich, dieses Hotel, WLAN, dieser Hotspot der äh haftet jetzt nicht dafür, was was ich tue. Ja? Wenn ich aber zu Hause ein freies WLAN betreibe.
Sich da jemand einwählt und dann sagen wir mal etwas tut, dann hafte ich da sehr wohl für.
Das ist etwas, was eigentlich nicht in diesem Gesetz steht, sondern was sich erst nachher in einem Urteil ergeben hat, in einem Gerichtsurteil. Ähm,
und deswegen soll es quasi, wurde schon vor langer Zeit von äh Ulf Buhrmeier, den wir ja auch hier schon zu Gast hatten in Lokbuchnetzpolitik, äh der Mitglied des Vereins digitale Gesellschaft ist. Ähm,
im Namen von des Vereines digitale Gesellschaft eben ein Gesetzesentwurf äh vorgeschlagen, der genau das dann nochmal regelt, dass man sagt, so dieser ähm,
Diese Klausel gilt auch für nichtgewerbliche Zugangsanbieter. Ähm Ulf hatte das mal in einem Vortrag äh vor dem Kongress,
neunundzwanzig zu drei oder so als äh Jura für Dummies bezeichnet, ja, dass man nochmal eigentlich einen Redundantensatz hinzufügt und sagt, äh das, wo hier steht, das gilt für alle, das gilt,
auch für die, so, ne? Aber ähm.
Das hatten die Linken schon mal eingebracht. Da wurde das dann äh äh sofort eingesackt, weil's von den Linken war. Jetzt wurde es also von grün unten linken äh äh eingebracht. Und wurde nun im Bundestag debattiert,
und dann äh sagte aber dann der Hans Jörg Durz von der CSU, dass für Netzbetreiber geltende Haftungsprivileg.
Bei zivilrechtlichen Verstößen einfach auf WLAN-Anbieter auszudehnen, sei aber zu simpel.
Und einen Schnellschuss zu Lasten der Rechteinhaber und IT-Sicherheit,
darf es nicht geben, sagte dann Axel Knörig von der CDU. Alles profilierte und bekannte äh CDU äh äh,
Internetexperten, ja, die hier also,
nachdem jahrelang dieses Land irgendwie zurückbleibt, hinter diesen, hinter diesen Regeln, ja? Ähm,
Wissen Sie jetzt also jetzt hier vor allem Schnellschuss zu warnen, denn es darf kein Freifahrtschein für Urheberrechtsverletzer geben. Und das ist natürlich, da haben Sie natürlich einen Punkt, aber es zeigt eben auch Ihre.
Ihre äh Prioritäten in dieser Thematik, ja, dass sie sagen, natürlich wäre es so, ähm,
Wenn ich also jetzt ein freies WLAN bereitstelle, dann und andere Leute darüber äh sagen wir mal Urheberrechte verletzen und nicht dafür nicht hafte und ich nicht nicht herausfinden kann, wer diese Menschen sind, dann äh würde ihm keiner haften. Dann wäre das jetzt eben mal geschehen.
Und äh darf dafür sorgen sie sich, weil es ja so ein großes Problem ist,
in Deutschland und wir sehen, wie alle Darben und Hinsichten außer natürlich die Anwälte, die mit diesen Abmahnungen äh wunderschönes Geld verdienen.
Und die brennenden.
Und jetzt sagt er aber, der Christian von der SPD-Fraktion, wir werden auf einen angemessenen Ausgleich aller beteiligten hinarbeiten, auch der rechte Inhaber. Ja, das heißt, mit anderen Worten.
Eventuell tun wir mal was, aber gut, dass wir darüber gesprochen haben.
Die müssen eigentlich ganz schön äh in der Zahl stecken, hat man so so den Eindruck, ne?
Wer steckt in der Zahl?
Also ich meine, das haben die sicherlich nicht selber ausgedacht.
Naja, da wenn die halt irgendwie äh also ich meine, dieser Abmahnerei ist ist ein ist ein massives Einkommen, insbesondere für einerseits diese für Anwälte und andererseits für die für die Rechte Inhaber.
Und das ist natürlich längst bei denen als ein Posten für einer, als Einnahmequelle drin. Und wenn es Gesetze gibt, die irgendwie direkt deine Einnahmen äh berühren,
Dein Geschäftsmodell berühren, dann äh kaufst du dir halt ein Zugticket nach Berlin und äh sprichst da mal mit ein paar Leuten und wenn du halt jemand bist, der Millionen mit dem Mist verdienst, verdient, äh dann schickst du halt auch eine Menge Leute dahin und dann sagst du halt hier, schau mal,
es kann ja wohl nicht sein. Das.
Genau, kann ja wohl nicht sein. Na ja.
Kann ja wohl nicht sein.
Also macht auf jeden Fall nicht so den Eindruck, als ob in dieser Störerhaftung äh Diskussion jetzt viel Bewegung ist, aber der Widerstand ist im Wesentlichen ein Widerstand der CDU und nicht unbedingt ein Widerstand der Regierung äh in dem Sinne als das die SPD sich hier jetzt,
nicht so negativ dazu.
Wir werden auf einen angemessenen Ausgleich.
Meinst du, sie sind dann auf einen Kompromis.
Irgendwo angemessener Ausgleich dran gestanden,
Hat jemals irgendwo angemessener Ausgleich dran gestanden, wo man sagte, das ist jetzt aber mal eine tolle Idee. Also weiß ich nicht, ne? Ist jetzt eingemessener Ausgleich. Klingt halt schön und das ist so eine klassische Floskel für äh da werden wir länger für brauchen.
Jetzt erstmal auf die lange Bank. Ähnlich wie diesen ähm Freedom-Act. Der ist ja jetzt nicht vom Tisch, der wird nur in dieser Legislaturperiode nicht mehr diskutiert werden.
Ja, ist auch sicherlich ein sehr angemessener Ausgleich.
Ganz anders sieht's ja mit den Reaktionen auf die NSA äh Sachen aus in der Wirtschaft, ne. Wir hatten da ja vor einigen Folgen schon mal drüber gesprochen, dass jetzt irgendwie äh Apple,
andere Sicherheits ähm Einstellungen zum für seine Nutzer und ähm.
Den Eindruck vermittelt, dass diese jetzt äh besser geschützt werden vom Zugriff durch äh Law and Forcement. Ähm das war so ein Beispiel,
Wir haben gesehen, dass irgendwie äh Google und so irgendwie massiv an der Verbesserung ihrer äh Verschlüsselungsinfrastrukturen gearbeitet haben und so.
Alle, als ich meine, im Prinzip haben sie erstmal vor allem die offensichtlichen Fehler und Fehlannahmen begradigt, so wie in ihrem
Netz unverschlüsselt übertragen et cetera. Ähm da wird jetzt überhaupt sehr viel Housekeeping äh gemacht, was man sich eigentlich schon früher gewünscht hätte, aber es muss halt dann auch mal erstmal was brennen, bevor reagiert wird. Das kennt man ja. Das ist jetzt auch nicht sonderlich überraschend. Interessanterweise äh kann man aber feststellen,
ähm aus der Sicht dieser Unternehmen hat es jetzt auch gebrannt.
Das ist richtig und bei ein Unternehmen, bei dem man jetzt eigentlich nicht den Eindruck hatte, dass es bei denen jetzt gebrannt hätte, weil es bei denen schon so oft gebrannt hat, dass sie jetzt aus Security-Perspektive eigentlich ohnehin in Ruinen standen.
Das war WhatsApp.
Ja, WhatsApp ähm wurde dann ja irgendwie vor einiger Zeit äh von Facebook gekauft für wie viel haben die dafür ausgegeben? Neunzehn Milliarden oder was?
Ja.
Also mehr als mehr als so als ich verdiene, ne? Und äh.
Geringfügig mehr, als ich mir vorstellen kann, wie ich weiß noch nicht mal, wie viele Nullen das ist. Ja, ähm.
Pro Jahr.
Naja, weil die mit diesen Million, Million, Billion und so, die Amerikaner, die zählen ja auch noch anders, ne, aber okay. Die haben.
Kommt man schnell durcheinander.
Ja, auf jeden Fall ziemlich teures ziemlich teurer Kauf, war WhatsApp für Facebook und WhatsApp ähm trat jetzt gestern auf und sagte, ja ähm.
Wir rollen jetzt übrigens Ende zu Ende Verschlüsselung aus für,
unsere sechshundert Millionen Kunden. Und zwar nutzen sie das ähm,
Protokoll ähm von Text Secure. Ist also ein instant Messaging ähm,
Ende zu Ende Verschlüsselungsprotokoll, das hauptsächlich seine Stärke darin hat, äh dass es ähm.
Auch funktioniert, wenn beide Partner oder wenn einer der beiden Partner,
im Moment nicht erreichbar ist mit mit anderen Worten, ist auch egal, ja? Sie können auch beide nicht erreichbar sein. Ähm,
Das war immer so die Schwäche bei Instant Messaging Protokollen, dass sie nämlich so wie OTR am Anfang so ein Handshake machen wollen, wo sie sich aufn äh Session äh Schlüssel einigen.
Und äh Texte, die Leute, die haben das quasi um, das ist so das Team, um maximalen Spike. Ähm die haben da einfach mal eine Lösung gezimmert und haben gesagt, okay,
Wir bauen das jetzt mal so hin, äh dass man auch äh quasi nicht synchron,
Ende zu Ende verschlüsseln kann,
in äh Kurznachrichten. Und das haben sie als äh das war so eine App äh für gab's, glaube ich, für iPhone und ähm,
und Android und so und deren äh Protokoll, da haben äh einige Leute äh ihren kritischen Blick drauf geworfen und das für sehr gut befunden,
und Moxy ist in diesem Bereich eigentlich jemand, der einen ziemlich,
ziemlich guten Ruf hat, nicht nur technisch, sondern auch was seine.
Sage ich mal, die die politische Einstellung und sein Verantwortungsgefühl äh in diesen Bereichen angeht, ja. Und ähm.
Gleichzeitig aber auch jemand, der schon die wirklich interessantesten Arbeit äh hatte, hat äh glaube ich eine Zeit lang auch die Sicherheit bei Twitter verantwortet und ähm,
ein ähm ein Mann mit einem sehr guten Ruf, der immer wieder für Überraschungen zu haben ist. Kann man, glaube ich, da.
Ja, kleine Korrektur, ähm kleine Korrektur, Texte gibt's in dem Sinne nur für Anrit und.
Mal, das habe ich aber hier auf meinem iPhone.
Das würde mich jetzt überraschen.
Ach nee, das war. Das ist von äh von von den Leuten, von den Guardian-Leuten, glaube ich, ne? Äh.
Ja, es tummeln sich mittlerweile so einige äh Systeme und ähm ja gibt's auf beiden.
Entschuldigung. Macht genau macht genau OTR und nicht das und ist von.
Ja warte mal, das ist nämlich ganz kurz, wer das entwickelt hat.
Äh welche Person da äh konkret dahinter stand.
Ja, genau, weil ich äh.
Hier ist von.
Das sind die Guardian-Leute. Das sind Hans äh und Christoph und so äh Steiner, äh Amerikaner, äh die um dieses ganze Guardian Projekt sind.
Mhm.
Und ich habe das jetzt durcheinandergebracht, weil ich die alle drei auf ein und der gleichen Konferenz mal getroffen habe und wir darüber gesprochen haben. Deswegen tut mir das leid.
Genau, es gab ja vor Kurzem ein ein äh
ein ein Test bei der äh IFF, die sich äh so alle halbwegs populären Messenger, Protokolle mal ganz genau angeschaut hat und äh eine sogenannte Secure Messaging Score Card ähm
entsprechend verfasst hat. Ähm ich glaube, da hatten wir hatten wir noch nicht drüber gesprochen.
Nähe habe ich auch aus einem guten Grund nicht gemacht, aber.
Jetzt mache ich das mal ohne ohne deinen guten Grund äh zu kennen, wie auch immer, auf jeden Fall,
Hierbei sind sowohl als auch verhältnismäßig gut weggekommen. Da gab's viele grüne Haken und WhatsApp halt äh nicht so sehr, weil die Verschlüsselung
von WhatsApp im Prinzip nicht existent war und sie eben keine richtige Ente zu Endeverschlüsselung sowieso äh hatten und jetzt haben sie halt angekündigt, dass sie diese Technik, also die Open-Source Technik von Wismar Systems übernehmen und ja, überall einbauen.
Was ja an sich ist erstmal.
Sie haben jetzt nicht einfach die die Open Source Technik von von äh übernommen, sondern sie haben ähm sich den äh Moxi ins Haus geholt,
der hat das äh das das Texte Team hat den das äh implementiert. Ja? Ähm.
Bei der bei der Score Card von der IFF fällt halt auf, dass ähm.
Die Kriterien, die sind jetzt nicht schlecht gewählt, aber äh die sind schon so, dass eigentlich alle.
Na ja, die Leute, die da jetzt halt volle Punktzahl kriegen oder die die Tools, die deine volle Punktzahl kriegen, sind halt ein ähm.
Nur sehr wenige, während sie so alle aus einem gleichen Dunstkreis entstammen. Ja, das macht halt dieses System oder dieses Gorcard so ein bisschen angreifbar.
Wirklich schlecht sind,
Das ist halt genau, also es ist halt genau ähm äh mit Krypto-Cat, ähm dann diesem äh und OTR und Textsecure. Ist das so alles die das sind alles ähm.
Open Source Tools, die äh gefundet werden aus dem äh aus aus ähnlichen ähm Mitteln.
Und diese Crowd äh da kennt man sich eben drin.
Ja gut, ich bin die Fragestellung war halt auch so, dass äh Open Source quasi automatisch schon mal zwei Punkte erreichen kann, die halt geschlossene Lösungen so nicht.
Genau und das ist ja das ist genau der Punkt, den ich anspreche,
Genau, Tim, das ist der Punkt, den ich anspreche, dadurch, dass es nicht so, dass diese Kriterien unbedingt falsch sind, aber sie führen eben zu einem Ergebnis, da in dem sich diese Aufstellung halt angreifbar gemacht hat
Dadurch, dass sie halt nur dazu geführt hat, dass genau ihr Dunstkreis halt da äh bevorzugt wird. Ähm das sagt nichts über die Kriterien aus,
Aber ähm diese Liste ist eben so ein bisschen, ja, äh ich würde sie eher als ähm,
als äh pädagogisch wertvoll sehen, da sie ja am Ende über die wirkliche Sicherheit des Tools nichts aussagt, denn,
Jetzt müsste ja auch WhatsApp entsprechend da korrigiert werden,
und hätte dann eben auch die volle Punktzahl. Und da kommen wir dann nämlich genau zu dem äh zu diesem,
Aspekt der jetzt natürlich interessiert, warum hat WhatsApp das jetzt getan?
Und da gibt's natürlich wenn man jetzt das das grundsätzliche Geschäftsmodell von von Facebook, dem Eigner von WhatsApp mal in Erwägung zieht deren,
Monetarisierung ja oder deren Geschäftsmodell darauf basiert, dass sie,
Nutzerdaten irgendwie monetarisieren und die Kommunikationsdaten und eigentlich auch zumindest bei Facebook Kommunikationsinhalte monetarisieren. Ähm dann stellt sich natürlich die Frage, warum machen die jetzt diesen Schritt,
Vor allem, wenn sie gerade für diese Firma neunzehn Milliarden ausgegeben haben. Ähm das könnte jetzt natürlich sein, dass ihr es wirklich aus aus absoluter ähm,
aus absolutem Humanismus machen und sagen, wir wollen Gutes tun, wir wollen,
die Regierung verärgern, wir wollen mal unsere Muskeln spielen lassen, ja?
So ganz so abwegig ist das ja nicht. Kapitalismus ist ja dafür bekannt. Äh sehe ja nach dem nach dem ne, also immer das Gute für den Menschen herauszuarbeiten.
Liebe Hörer, der Tim ist heute so ein bisschen eigenartig. Ich habe das gerade schon im Vorgespräch gemerkt, verzeiht ihm das. Also.
Wolltest du mal gesagt haben?
So, die ähm,
die ähm die so, genau. Also sie werden das wahrscheinlich, sie werden egal wie tief sie vielleicht in ihr eigenes Fleisch damit schneiden, ihre eigenen finanziellen Interessen nicht vollständig außer Acht gelassen haben. Und eine äh.
Überlegung ist natürlich so, man könnte jetzt sagen, na ja.
Dass die der die tatsächliche WhatsApp äh kommt ja immer noch als als closed-sourced Produkt,
Das heißt, ich kann jetzt nicht erkennen, ob da drin nicht eventuell eine Vektor versteckt ist, die äh es dann vielleicht doch ermöglicht, äh für den Fall, dass ich ein IS-Terrorist bin, den,
äh Verschlüsselung doch irgendwie zu brechen oder an an mein Kiematerial heranzukommen. Ähm.
Es könnte aber auch sein, dass das Ding wirklich nach allen Regeln der Kunst gebaut haben und sagen, ist uns doch scheißegal, was die Leute sich da in ihren äh Kurznachrichten schicken,
Uns interessiert doch eh nur, wer mit wem befreundet ist. Und wir wollen uns interessiert Netzwerkinformationen.
Dass man sagt, okay, über das bisschen Inhalte, äh was da noch drin steht, brauchen wir uns doch am Ende gar nicht zu streiten. Und das ähm,
scheint ähm glaube ich die der realistischere, die realistische Interpretation dessen zu sein, weshalb ich sage.
Egal wie man's nimmt. Und da jetzt irgendwelche äh Backdoors drin zu vermuten, äh ist eben eine,
wäre eben wirklich im Bereich der Verschwörungstheorien, wobei ich sie mir gleichzeitig sagen muss, ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass äh äh WhatsApp.
Da nicht tatsächlich noch irgendeine Vektor drin hat. Aber das ist eben äh äh Spekulation und Verschwörungstheorie. Ähm der Punkt ist dieser Schritt zeigt auf jeden Fall, dass Metadaten alles andere als wertlos sind.
Denn sonst hätte WhatsApp ja jetzt gerade alles, was irgendwie als Geschäftsmodell in diesem Ding gesteckt hätte, äh zerschlagen.
Das das tun sie durch diesen Move,
Ich meine, rein jetzt so aus kapitalistischen Erwägungen oder aus äh wettbewerbstechnischen Erwägungen ist es natürlich so, WhatsApp steht mittlerweile in äh unmittelbarer Konkurrenz zu
Systemen wie Leinen und Wechseln et cetera, die ja ähm im asiatischen Raum ganz weit vorne sind
eben mit so chinesischer Software und äh der dem Verhältnis zum Staat äh ist, dass
glaube ich, schon ganz gut ausmalen
Ja, da gibt's äh alle möglichen Zensurmechanismen, die jetzt auch jüngst wieder schön zum Vorschein kamen, als äh diese Proteste in Hongkong anfing
dann auf einmal bestimmte Nachrichten irgendwie auf äh überhaupt gar nicht mehr durchkamen. Also sind alles so Systeme, die mittlerweile auch dort im Fokus sind. Und das ist natürlich dann in dem Sinne für Facebook jetzt auch ein
ein Sales-Argument sozusagen, ein Verbreitungsargument, wenn Sie sagen, ja hier WhatsApp, wir verschlüsseln Ende zu Ende und wir gehen da nicht rein. Wenn Sie das sagen.
Das ist ein das ist äh das ist wichtig, dass äh du das auch nochmal ansprichst. Ähm.
Dieser ganze IT-Sicherheitskram ist ja schon auch ein Interesse der USA. Ähm,
dass Menschen da irgendwie generell mal Zugriff zu haben, denn sie haben ja zum Beispiel ähm also das Torprojekt zum Beispiel wird auch so zum Beispiel von äh Open Technology Fund gefördert. Ähm,
dessen ursprüngliches äh oder deren nach wie vor äh Miss Mission Statement ist in insbesondere in Asien. Ähm,
Oppositionellen und Unterdrücken äh Möglichkeiten zu liefern, ihre Meinungsfreiheit aufrechtzuerhalten.
Das heißt, die exportieren die Fan gezielt die Entwicklung von Tor mit dem Ziel.
Ähm in Asien ja oppositionellen Sicherheit und,
eine Sphäre des freien Austausches zu schaffen. Und das kann natürlich einerseits.
Ist das einfach mal ein ein etwas grundsätzlich Gutes und passt natürlich eben auch in die Staatsraison der USA hinein. Das heißt, ähm die die haben,
Es ist durchaus in deren Interesse, dass äh äh Diszidenten in anderen Ländern äh Sicherheit zur Verfügung steht.
Das kann hier durchaus auch äh im sowohl im finanziellen Interesse von WhatsApp sein als auch in in der äh politischen Resort der USA.
Also sollte zumindest könnte.
Es ist, es ist eine spannende Sache. Also ich diese diese Nachricht äh die wurde natürlich heiß debattiert, ne? Es gab dann einerseits welche geschrieben haben, ja, geil, geil, geil, geil, geil. Äh jetzt kann ich irgendwie wieder schön äh WhatsApp nutzen,
Es gab andere, die natürlich dann laut geschrien haben, äh oh je ähm,
Das ist ja jetzt eine Falle, ne, die wollen uns jetzt einlohnen, die verarschen uns, das ist bestimmt und weißt du nicht. Ähm,
eine Sache ist, ist äh grundsätzlich äh daran aber als fröhlich zu begrüßen, als als schön zu begrüßen. Und das ist.
Es hebt einfach mal, es setze einfach jetzt einen Standard, ja? Du kannst jetzt einfach mit keinem Messenger mehr irgendwo antreten,
der nicht konkurrenzfähig zu WhatsApp ist. Ja? Also wenn selbst WhatsApp dieses Sicherheitsfeature hat,
dann brauchst du halt mit nichts anderem mehr anzutreten, was dieses Sicherheitsfeature nicht bietet. Und das geht übrigens auch über Messenger hinaus, denn wie äh mir über Twitter sehr freundlich in Erinnerung gerufen wurde,
WhatsApp ist damit jetzt sicherer als eine D-Mail.
Und das ist echt geil, ja. Also äh auch wenn ich nach wie vor jetzt kein begeisterter WhatsApp-Nutzer bin, äh muss ich sagen, das sind schon echt tolle ähm,
politische Argumentation Argumente, die einem da jetzt in die Hand gelegt werden, ja? Also ich glaube, ich habe äh ich weiß nicht, ob ich, also ne?
So per WhatsApp, so ah, ich würde ihnen lieber eine WhatsApp schreiben, das ist ehrlich gesagt sicherer, so.
Ja
Ja, also kritische Sachen, die ab jetzt nur noch per WhatsApp.
Ja, also ich ich begrüße die Entwicklung, ja. Äh ich begrüße die Entwicklung.
Gemeinsam. Und äh ich,
Es zeigt auch übrigens ich erinnere mich jetzt gerade nochmal hier an diese ähm Debatte, die geführt wurde auf dem zehnten Geburtstagstreffen von Sitzpolitik Org,
Ich glaube, da hatte ich ja mit Thomas drüber gesprochen über den äh Tag und ähm unter anderem gab's ja da auch diese Diskussion oder dieses Panel mit ähm Frank Rieger und mit ähm,
Sascha Lobo, ja, wo nochmal schön so die äh zwei grundsätzlichen,
also grundsätzlich unterschiedlichen Sichten auch so der Hackergemeinde und der äh weniger Hackergemeinde auf dieses äh Thema nochmal zum Vorschein trat, weil.
Zum Beispiel stark den Punkt vertrag, na ja,
politisch kriegt man da irgendwie nix bewegt. Äh wir müssen jetzt da einfach Hand anlegen und versuchen äh die Sicherheit des Internets einfach so weit zu verbessern, wie es nur irgendwie möglich ist
es einfach teuer werden muss, diese Überwachung durchzuführen und es gäbe sehr viele Ansatzpunkte, ähm die sehr viel teurer zu machen
Ähm ja, ne, Sascha Lubo-Vertrat da eine äh andere Sichtweise und glaubte sozusagen an die Veränderbarkeit der Politik, wenn man denn nur dabei wäre und das als eben technisch sicher nichts machen ließe.
Ich weiß nicht ganz genau, wie du das äh so bewertest. Ich habe da so eine Vermutung, aber ich persönlich bin da ganz auf der Seite von Frank, weil ich eben denke, wenn man sich den derzeitigen Zustand anschaut des Netzes.
So viel im Arsch und so viel verbesserungswürdig. Ist zwar ein langer Weg, bis man da auch wirklich auf breiter Frontverbesserung durchgeführt hat, aber stimmt natürlich schon, dass eben grade so eine ein relativ einfachen Schritte, also populäre Dienste setzen auf eine
Verschlüsselung
dass das eben den Zugriff auf Kommunikationswege doch erheblich erschwert, also dass sozusagen der Aufwand da reinzugehen, entweder technisch mit einem sehr großen Aufwand äh verbunden ist, der ohnehin schon getrieben wird, aber es wird eben auch den Diensten recht einfach gemacht
beziehungsweise der eben dann auch immer wiederum das Ausnutzen möglicherweise sogar von Illegalen Wegen durch die Geheimdienste
erforderlich macht, um an, an diese Kommunikationsströme heranzukommen, was halt ab einer bestimmten Dichte dann eben auch mal auffliegen kann, wie wir gesehen haben.
Und insofern finde ich eben auch diesen Trend der großen Anbieter jetzt hier auch äh da ein Markt zu sehen für Verschlüsselungen und vielleicht künftig auch noch für andere Aspekte der Kommunikation finde ich äh ist positiv.
Ja, ist absolut positiv. Um noch kurz zu sagen, also selbstverständlich äh schließen sich ja diese beiden äh Maßnahmen überhaupt nicht aus, ne? Und äh,
insofern denke ich natürlich, dass man auch weiter auf auf der politischen Ebene.
Arbeiten kann, sollte und muss, aber äh gleichzeitig äh sich eben auf der technischen Ebene äh auch mal die Hot Fixes äh einspielen sollte.
Ja, einen Hot Fix braucht auch äh Obama. Hat man so den Eindruck, jetzt wo er sich äh mit
trösen Zwischenwahl, die ja eigentlich immer so verläuft in den USA, konfrontiert sieht und äh wieder so ein
an eine Mehrheit ähm Beschaffungsverhinderungsmaschine da installiert wurde durch die Republikaner.
Dass er, ja, weiß ich nicht, so ein bisschen jetzt als gilt, trotzdem hat er jetzt vollmundig angekündigt, dass er Netzneutralität auf einmal ganz toll findet und dass er äh ja seine präsidialen äh Befugnisse doch gerne zum Einsatz bringen möchte, um dort
klare Regeln zum Schutz von Netzneutralität aufzustellen. Ich habe jetzt einen Vortrag dazu nicht gesehen
Was hatte denn da äh genannt, was er denn konkret tun möchte?
Also man muss mal kurz sagen, sein seine Vorliebe für Netzneutralität hat er nicht erst jetzt entdeckt, das war schon Wahlkampfthema von ihm. Ähm.
Er hat letztendlich in diesem Video nur seine äh seine Position,
Seine Definition von Netzneutralität einmal heruntergebetet, gesagt, warum sie wichtig ist und dass er die äh FCC Federal Community.
Wartewurf, ich weiß, fragt mich gerade, wofür das zweite C steht. Kurz mal den Google anwerfen. Comission natürlich, Commission. Favorit Communications Commission ähm auffordert,
da in seinem Sinne zu entscheiden, ja?
Ähm der Hintergrund ist aber natürlich, dass die äh FCC.
Ähm im Moment da eher in eine andere äh,
Richtung Arbeit, denn so im April war das ungefähr stellte sich ja dann in Aussicht, dass die FCC die Netzneutralität in USA nämlich eher aufweichen will und ähm,
quasi Beschleunigungsspuren ein äh führen wollte, also bestimmte Daten gegen Gebühr schneller weiterzuleiten als Daten nicht zahlender Personen und Firmen. Und ähm.
Dass äh werden wir jetzt sehen.
Welche Möglichkeiten Obama da jetzt wirklich hat äh auf die Einfluss auszuüben, ja? Aber es ist natürlich schon mal äh spannend, wenn der Präsident äh sich da in in solcher.
Klarheit äußert. Das ist schon ähm,
Das heißt nicht, dass das von heute bis, äh von heute auf morgen genauso umgesetzt wird, aber,
Das ist schon mal ein ähm ein starkes Signal, während wir heute die Meldung.
Aus der aus der EU bekommen dass man nun angestrengt ist nämlich die Netzneutralitätsregeln möglichst zu verbessern,
Also da kommen da hören wir genau heute ein ein ganz anderes Signal.
Ähm wo man nämlich gerne äh dafür hin oder darauf hinarbeiten möchte, dass äh.
In Kommunikationsanbieter bestimmten Inhalteanbieter äh spezialisierte äh Dienste anbieten sollen. Ja, also es ist genau das, was die FC auch machen möchte.
Ähm.
Nur der in in den USA hat jetzt der Präsident gesagt, äh das äh soll jetzt hier mal mein Erbe sein und dafür werde ich kämpfen und ist mir scheißegal.
Wir werden sehen, welche welche Wirkung er da entfalten wird, ja.
Na gut, schauen wir mal, wie das genau mit dem Erbe ist es ja noch nicht so richtig weit bisher in seinem Projekt. Ja, dann gibt's einen Personalwechsel.
Ja, den hatten wir schon angekündigt beim BKA. Ähm.
Jetzt ist er vollzogen.
Dass der ist jetzt vollzogen. Es war nämlich die Herbsttagung des BKA und da wurde dann der Herr äh Zirke verabschiedet und ähm.
Wirklich interessant, ja? Also ich meine, das ist halt eine, also der politisierungsgrad dieses Bundeskriminalamtes, ist schon echt äh erstaunlich, ne? Ich meine,
diese gesamte NSU äh Recherche vollständig verkackt und das gehörte wahrscheinlich auch zu deren politischen Programm. Anders kann man sich das ja gar nicht vorstellen. Ähm.
Und da tritt dann der Innenminister auf und stellt irgendwelche politischen Forderungen,
in der Eröffnungsrede und sagt, er er möchte eine selbstbewusste und mutige Stellungnahme der Polizisten,
zur Vorratsdatenspeicherung und zu weiteren, dringenden, dringend notwendigen Ermittlungsbefugnissen, ja? Das ist eigentlich echt witzig, ja, da geht so einer hin, da geht so ein Innenminister hin und sagt, Freunde.
Ich möchte, dass ihr selbstbewusst.
Und mutig fordert welche Ermittlungs äh Werkzeuge wir euch äh zur Verfügung stellen sollen.
Das finde ich schon, das finde ich also interessant, ja. Und ähm Fokus dieser Herbsttagung war dann,
die organisierte Kriminalität und da wusste ja dann zu berichten bei der organisierten Kriminalität wirkt das Internet wie ein Brandbeschleuniger.
Ja
Wir blicken durch einen gleichbleibendes Schlüsselloch in ein gleichbleibenden auf einen gleichbleibenden Ausschnitt und eine ständig wachsende Szene.
Selbst in jeder Zeitung steht das, die Deliktzahlen grade fallen, ja? Und das ist halt wirklich einfach mal nachweislich falsch ist, was er da sagt. Und dass er da einfach so eine Brandrede hält, ne.
Und das Schlimmste, was wir jetzt gerade so haben, das Schlimmste, das merkt ihr, das wisst ihr alle. Ist äh Medikamentenfälschung,
Das ist eines unserer eines unserer größten Sorgen. Ähm das äh gefälschte Medikamente übers Internet vertrieben werden, ja?
Und ähm.
Was ich sehr schön fand, ist seine Rede endete dann damit, dass er ähm verlorenes Vertrauen in der Bevölkerung in diese Maßnahmen zurückgewinnen möchte. Und er lässt sich dann zitieren, mit,
Es wird generell zu viel an Inhalten über uns gespeichert. Die Verbindungsdaten sind viel weniger. Ja, also schließlich auch nochmal schön dieser Kreis zu dieser WhatsApp Sache,
er jetzt sagt, wir wollen,
überall, wo wir Inhalte speichern. Lasst es sein, Datenschutz, liebe Datenschützer, macht mit. Wir wollen einfach nur die Metadaten haben, den Rest holen wir uns dann schon selber. Und das ist natürlich auch eine,
ähm eine Ermittlungsstrategie, äh die man,
verargumentieren kann, dass man sagt, komm, Meterdaten von allen, auf Basis der Metadaten,
bilden wir dann halt Verdachtsmomente und Hypothesen und dann äh drucken wir halt die Serienbriefe für die Richteranforderungen äh für die,
Richter wie nennt man das? Durchsuchungsbefehle oder was da, ne? Ähm.
Mir fehlt jetzt gerade das Wort. Um den um den Richter Vorbehalt Genüge zu tun, dann stellen wir da die Anträge äh und dann können wir äh entsprechend äh dann auch
ja? Und das kann man halt so äh verargumentieren, ja. Die Frage ist halt so, möchte die Gesellschaft ihre Metadaten vollständig
überwacht, erfasst und durch Algorithmen kontrolliert wissen. So, mit diesen Worten wurde dann der liebe Holger Münch,
in seinem neuen Job willkommen geheißen? Sein Auftrag.
Das nennt man dann wohl ah, das nennt man dann wohl Agenda Setting.
Das ist äh ziemlich klar, äh was da jetzt seine.
Was da jetzt eine äh Agenda ist für die nächste Zeit. Das ist sein Arbeitsauftrag,
Die Briten, die Briten müssen natürlich auch was gegen den Terror tun, aber die überwachen ja schon alles,
Also sind die jetzt inzwischen schon wieder beim zensieren. Die hatten ja jetzt gerade erst im Anfang diesen Jahres ihren komischen äh Pornofilter da eingeschaltet. Äh der äh bei den großen vier Pro Weilern dann da aktiv ist,
und mit äh diesen Providern werden jetzt auch äh Diskussionen darüber äh geführt, ob man denn diese,
die Diskussionen sind abgeschlossen, es wird geschehen, dass man diese Filterinfrastruktur, diese schöne Filterinfrastruktur, die man da doch jetzt hat, ob man die jetzt nicht auch mal eben schnell gegen terroristische und andere extremistische Inhalte im Netz äh richtet.
Und außerdem äh das ist auch eine Idee, die immer wieder kommt, die ist die ist äh wunderschön. Äh möchte man gerne einen Meldebutton haben,
das ist echt ganz geil. Das ist dann so wegen neben, weißt du, so neben Facebook, Like und Flatter und äh und was was gibt's noch für Bartels?
Twitter und äh alles Mögliche.
Amazon Kindle Button.
Dienst gibt's irgendwie einen passenden Button.
Genau und da wird's jetzt kommt jetzt bald noch einer daneben. Das ist dann halt der Meldebuttonterror.
Können wir bei uns auch schon mal einfügen. Den habe ich vor Jahren schon mal zweitausendelf oder so für für Netzpolitik ORG designed und da habe ich mich äh,
Logo äh orientiert, ne? Notrufknopf fürs Internet wollte damals die EU haben. Jetzt gibt's also einen Meldebutton für Porno. Das ist äh für für Terror, das ist natürlich auch eine schöne Sache, da da ist Missbrauch ja quasi ausgeschlossen, ne.
Dass irgendwie deine Webseite demnächst irgendwie in in Großbritannien nicht mehr erreichbar ist, weil irgendeiner mal schnell auf den äh Terror-Button gedrückt hat,
Ist übrigens auch eine Forderung vom Bund der Kriminalbeamten in Deutschland, also nichts, was man jetzt als besonders äh weltfremd äh hier in Deutschland,
bezeichnet oder gar den Kopf drüber schütteln schön könnte. Immerhin im Juli,
stellte sich, glaube ich, heraus, dass diese Filter äh noch immer von weniger als zehn Prozent der Nutzer überhaupt äh,
tatsächlich genutzt werden, was natürlich schon mal ganz,
Ganz positiv ist. Gleichzeitig gab's dann die Meldung, dass die Filter damals schon rund ein Fünftel der beliebtesten Webseiten sperren würden. Also,
ein bisschen am Ziel vorbeigehen. Wobei ich jetzt den Artikel nicht so genau gelesen habe, ob vielleicht nicht einfach ein Fünftel der beliebtesten Webseiten eben auch.
Liebeswebseiten sind.
Was äh Schaukelvideos.
Videos, Schaukelfotos und so, das ist ja alles die Internet is about Love.
Das Gleiche. Die Internet ist abschaukeln.
Äh kommen wir langsam äh kommen wir langsam zum Ende. Ähm ich bin ja gerade äh in,
Österreich mal ausnahmsweise.
Was ist verraten.
Und äh,
wenn ich wenn ich äh manchmal verrate ich das ja auch. Da habe ich mir auch was bei gedacht, das jetzt zu verraten. Ähm und zwar habe ich gestern mit dem Thomas noch ein Bierchen getrunken. Thomas Lohning an,
und äh die haben ja die Vorratsdatenspeicherung in Österreich äh,
abgeschafft und Thomas hatte das, glaube ich, auch schon als er das letzte Mal bei Logbuch Netzpolitik zu Gast war angekündigt. Sie haben sich jetzt zum Ziel gesetzt, äh alle Überwachungsgesetze in Österreich zu evaluieren.
Ähm das ist natürlich ein größeres Vorhaben, von dem sie jetzt die Hälfte finanziert haben,
und die anderen fünfundzwanzigtausend Euro, die die Sache jetzt noch brauchen, die hätten sie ganz gerne gespendet,
und ähm ich finde das mal ähm wirklich eine schöne Initiative, auch mal so wirklich in die ähm.
In die Offensive zu gehen und zu sagen, so wir schauen uns, wir nehmen jetzt hier ähm,
ein paar Juristen und so, wir evaluieren jetzt mal alle Überwachungsgesetze, so wie wir es eigentlich ja ähm vom Staat fordern würden, ist eine Forderung, die auch ich schon,
mal im Namen des CCC vertreten habe, dass man sagt, wenn du so ein Überwachungsgesetz machst, dann solltest du halt auch,
Evaluation, Evaluierungszeiträume definieren, dass du sagst, nach einem Jahr schauen wir, äh ob uns diese Vorratsdatenspeicherung irgendwas gebracht hat und wenn Sie uns nichts gebracht hat, dann schaffen wir sie wieder ab.
Natürlich äh ist zu erwarten, dass die tatsächliche
das tatsächliche Ergebnis einer solchen Evaluation natürlich immer dahingehend von den evaluierten verfälscht werden würde, dass man sagt, sie hat nichts gebracht, deswegen weiten wir sie jetzt aus, ja, aber mal überhaupt in äh in
Ein Wirknachweis für solche Überwachungsgesetze zu verlangen, äh ist natürlich ähm eine eine sehr sinnvolle, sehr rationale,
Forderung, wenn man sich überlegt, welchen,
welchen Grundrechtseinschränkungen man äh da äh Tür und Tor öffnet. Insofern finde ich dieses Projekt sehr unterstützenswert,
und möchte an dieser Stelle äh dazu auffordern, auffordern, sich an dieser Crowdfunding-Kampagne,
zu beteiligen. Die Thomas, wie gesagt, in einer vorangegangenen Folge schon nochmal ausführlicher äh erklärt hat auf die ich dann an dieser Stelle verweise.
Genau, nämlich äh hundertneunzehn. Vor.
Hundertneunzehn. Tim verweist an dieser Stelle.
Genau, ich verweise an dieser Stelle, beziehungsweise unsere Show-Notes, die ihr natürlich dann auch wieder äh,
konsultieren äh könnt. Wie immer mit äh allen feinen Links auf Nachrichtenseiten, wo all das, was wir hier zum Besten geben, nochmal ein bisschen genauer und vielleicht manchmal auch etwas weniger genau zusammengefasst ist.
Ne? Sorry, dass es jetzt für dich ein bisschen schockierend kommt, aber.
Jetzt fängt der hier an zu meckern, ey.
Die Leute sind ja nicht ehrlich da draußen, ne, die Welt äh ist ja manchmal ein bisschen schwierig.
Sorry, das hätte ich dir jetzt vielleicht nicht sagen sollen. Lass uns lieber äh lass uns lieber.
Die Welt schwierig ist, dann mache ich da nicht mit. Danken.
Lass uns lieber Danksagungen aussprechen.
Ja, danke, eine besondere Danksagung gilt äh dem Tom.
Und äh eine ganz besondere oder ebenso besondere Danksagung gilt dem Dirk, äh die durch äh besondere Unterstützung des Formates Lokbuch Netzpolitik zum Gelingen dieser Sendung beigetragen haben.
Genau und an der Stelle auch nochmal äh ein Danke an äh alle anderen, die zum Beispiel durch Nutzung von äh Flatterbuttons et cetera auch zur äh Unterstützung der Sendung beigetragen haben, vielleicht nicht in einem besonderen Maße, aber in einem Gleichwohl äh wichtigen und effektiven und wirkungsvollen
Basel. Ne? Müssen wir ja auch mal sagen. Und jetzt.
Kann man, kann man immer Flatterknöpfe drücken und so, das macht auch Spaß. Wir haben jetzt da einen Sound.
Haben wir. Ein Sound, wenn der, wenn der Flatterbutton äh gedrückt wird, ja, welchen Sand?
Ja, wenn es nicht klingelt, dann musst du nochmal einen anderen probieren.
Mal gucken. Ich weiß nicht, also ich höre jetzt gerade nichts, aber können wir mal gucken. Ah, doch.
Ja, geil, oder? Hast du mich jetzt geflattert oder wen?
Ganz einfach. Äh ja, klar, natürlich. Haben wir denn sonst die Lust? Wir sagen tschüss, bis bald. Das war's.
Bis bald, tschau, tschau.